avete mai avuto
coli
o che vi
consolava
lei riteneva i brutti pensieri beh io
penso di avere trovato nella mia
carriera
un eroe dei nostri tempi di essere la
persona che ha cominciato a studiarlo
presto nella sua carriera
questo eroe naturalmente l'oceano che ha
un aspetto importante ed è un grande
gigante gentile perché ricopre la terra
per la sua il 70 per cento a delle
specie viventi importantissime per
l'equilibrio del nostro pianeta ed è
diciamo uno dei tanti responsabile del
clima della terra e quello che modera
alcuni degli impatti del cambiamento
climatico
ma quanto tempo potrà fare questo
se non lo aiutiamo il nostro grande
gigante gentile è stato studiato per la
prima volta da un bolognese strano non
siamo vicini al mare ma forse lo eravamo
a quel tempo nel 1679 il conto e luigi
ferdinando marsili fece la prima vera e
propria campagna oceanografica eccolo in
questa sua bellissima immagine di
repertorio
lui era un militare ed era un
oceanografo era in realtà un grande
sperimentatore come una volta i grandi
sperimentatori erano mai con in più una
cosa come newton gli riconobbe ovvero di
andare in campo e di misurare la natura
non è facile nel 1679 fare questo e
quindi lui intraprende un lungo viaggio
con finalità diplomatiche da venezia a
istanbul
misurando per la prima volta il mare le
acque e conoscendo da queste misure come
si muove il mare
io questo lo studio ancora adesso siamo
ancora qui a cercare di rispondere
alcune delle sue domande ben fatte direi
e questo è un esperimento che oggi
facciamo con un computer
come vedete c'è lui fece invece in campo
lui andò nel bosforo misurò le acque sul
fondo l'eroe con la superficie e capi
che le acque sul fondo scalza vano
quelle alla superficie volevano quelle
superficiali che si muovevano ma era la
risposta alle acque profonde che
propagava in superficie qui cosa vedete
in questa figura le acque profonde sulle
acque bianche le acque leggere sono
quelle nere e avete visto che le acque
bianche si sono infiltrate sul fondo e
hanno mosso quelle nere e poi
rimescolate
questo succede nell'oceano tutti i
momenti e noi cerchiamo di studiarlo con
questi mezzi avanzati che sono anche le
simulazioni numeriche ma abbiamo bisogno
anche di osservazioni come marseille e
fece quindi marsili capi dalle sue
misure che l'oceano aveva due correnti
un in superficie che andava in una
direzione e una in profondità che andava
nell'altra
vediamo come si muove l'oceano visto in
una rappresentazione adesso del giorno
d'oggi
vediamo alla superficie le frecce ci
indicano il moto dell'acqua verso il
nord
questo è il fondo del mare e vedete che
a un certo punto queste frecce si
inabissano e nell'abisso vanno in
direzione contraria quella della
superficie esattamente come marsili capi
avendo in testa la gravità avendo in
testa la proprietà del fluido che al
tempo non era ancora conosciuta che era
la densità
ecco come si muove l'oceano ora questo è
il grande gigante gentile porta calore
dall'equatore verso i poli perde questo
suo calore acquista densità e va sul
fondo
si attacca a tutti i bacini oceanici a
diventa un serpentone che è chiamato il
serpentone climatico che moderando
impatto climatico sulla terra
naturalmente bisogna averne cura e
soprattutto bisogna conoscerlo per
poterne prevedere i cambiamenti forse
inaspettati questo è di nuovo e
serpentone il serpentone climatico della
nostra terra quello che regola il clima
della nostra terra perché l'atmosfera si
muove molto velocemente il mare assorbe
il calore dall'atmosfera e lo porta in
profondità quindi mettendolo conservando
la memoria degli eventi climatici e del
riscaldamento globale
quindi abbiamo le frecce rosse che
portano il calore dall'equatore al al
nord perdono calore e vamo sul fondo in
questo grande circolo bene come possiamo
prevenire che l'oceano abbia diciamo un
comportamento anomalo che possa cambiare
improvvisamente visto che è così
importante nella regolazione del clima
della terra boe al giorno d'oggi
vediamo prima di tutto in realtà come
sta cambiando l'oceano dal 1850 al 2000
l'oceano si è riscaldato di 0.5 gradi
centigradi e vedete una cosa
interessante che riscaldamento avvenuto
soprattutto negli ultimi 50 anni
quindi c'è un'accelerazione
riscaldamento è accelerato nell'oceano
il riscaldamento quando l'acqua si
riscalda si espande provoca assieme allo
scioglimento dei ghiacci prova che
l'innalzamento del livello del mare
quindi qua dal novecento al duemila dove
esiste il record osservativo vediamo
questo innalzamento queste sono prove
inconfutabili del cambiamento che il
nostro serpentone sta avendo tramite due
degli indici che gli scienziati usano
per vedere la salute del nostro oceano
come è cambiato l'oceano degli scorsi
negli scorsi 20 anni
negli scorsi vent'anni è successo una
rivoluzione silenziosa che molti non
conoscono e che l'oceano può essere
visto dai satelliti in una maniera mai
precedentemente possibile
e questa è un'immagine da satelliti di
come cambia il livello del mare sulla
terra negli scorsi 20 anni posso solo
darvi gli scorsi 20 anni perché è stata
eletti prima non misuravano quindi
vedete che ci sono delle regioni dove il
livello del mare cresce molte sono
quelle rosse e ci sono delle regioni
dove addirittura il livello del mare può
decrescere quindi il riscaldamento
innalzamento del livello del mare non è
uniforme ma nel mediterraneo bene questa
qui la figura stessa con gli stessi
colori per il mediterraneo in più ci
sono anche dei dati lungo le coste che
vengono raccolti dalle stazioni
ma la cosa importante che vedete che da
noi c'è parecchio rosso perché il
mediterraneo
è un po particolare riesce a
immagazzinare il calore in una maniera
particolare e forse estrema
quindi questo negli scorsi 100 anni e
questo mi discorsi 2000 queste sono le
piscine romane che ora sono sott'acqua è
questa che e una piscina romana di
vicino a civitavecchia è sicuramente ho
dovuto al riscaldamento globale
abbiamo prove non solo archeologiche ma
anche vere scientifiche del fatto che
stiamo cambiando e 20 anni fa gli
scienziati si sono chiesti come facciamo
a capire quello che sta succedendo tutti
i giorni sapere reagire a delle
emergenze eventualmente e ed è stata
inventata una nuova branca della scienza
oceanografica che è quella delle
previsioni del tempo del mare come si
facevano le previsioni per come si fanno
le previsioni per l'atmosfera adesso si
prevede il mare si prevede il mare dalla
superficie agli abissi per tutte le
correnti che vi si sviluppano e alcuni
di queste ve le farò vedere perché sono
veramente pelle e come cosa serve serve
avere delle osservazioni e serve avere
dei modelli modelli che possono
proiettare nel futuro
queste sono le sue azioni
al giorno d'oggi nel mese scorso tutti
questi puntini misuravano la temperatura
e la salinità o altre variabili del mare
e le tele trasmettono in tempo reale
entro un'ora
io posso sapere qual è la temperatura
nel pacifico o lungo le coste della
california
seduta nel mio studio all'unità di
bologna
questo sistema enorme di informazione
che continuamente gira fra di noi e
quello che ci permetterà di sapere che
cosa succede nel nostro c'erano da qui
sempre nel futuro ed è stato messo in
piedi nei discorsi vent'anni
questo è il modello numerico invece
modello numerico dove io prendo le
equazioni della fisica e descritto su
una griglia che mi permette di fare
conti su quello che sarà il futuro della
mia temperatura del mio livello del mare
siamo diventati bravi a fare questo ma
sono necessari enormi computer come
questo ne abbiamo uno molto importante a
bologna e sul centro di supercalcolo del
cineca e uno dei più importanti in
europa e al mondo e abbiamo bisogno di
questi enormi infrastrutture
tecnologiche per poter prevedere il
tempo del nostro oceano e del nostro
serpentone oggi la temperatura nel
mediterraneo è questa domani sarà così
possiamo ora a farvela vedere questa è
la superficie
riconoscete l'italia e vedete dai colori
che l'acqua più calda naturalmente sta a
est nel mediterraneo orientale fino alle
coste di israele o lungo la libia mentre
la parte più fredda è il nord adriatico
e la parte della riviera azzurra questo
invece è una rappresentazione quella è
la temperatura
questa è la rappresentazione invece di
come si muove l'acqua come marsili
l'aveva immaginata ma questa volta con
molto più dettaglio marsili aveva
misurato in tre punti e avere ed era
riuscito ma coscientemente a capire che
c'erano queste due correnti opposte
quando andiamo a vedere la complessità
invece questa ci sono vortici enormi
vortici isole isole che intrappolano la
plastica queste sono le isole che
intrappolano la plastica nell'oceano
e questa è la visione delle correnti su
tutto il globo
il centro euro mediterraneo per i
cambiamenti climatici che è un nostro
infrastruttura voluta dal governo
italiano ha realizzato per la prima
volta questa simulazione e previsione
questo è il tempo di oggi
in tutto l'oceano globale per fare
questo abbiamo bisogno di tutte quelle
osservazioni di capire come sono le
osservazioni di controllarla in tempo
reale e di avere questi enormi computer
con delle equazioni che naturalmente
sono in continuo sviluppo
beh ora ce l'abbiamo questa è una novità
è venuta fuori
diciamo nello spegnere discorsi due anni
e quindi questi sistemi ce ne sono tre o
quattro al mondo uno l'abbiamo noi in
italia
questa è la temperatura oggi di tutto
l'oceano globale
vedete come il mediterraneo per esempio
è contenuto nella banda tropicale non è
contenuto nella banda il freddo e il blu
e il rosso è naturalmente il caldo
quindi noi siamo parte di quella regione
che avrà l'impatto climatico più alto
bene quindi abbiamo fatto un enorme
innovazione tecnologica siano riusciti a
vedere tramite i satelliti tramite le
boe e capire avere i modelli per poter
prevedere nel futuro e quindi il momento
di ritornare in armonia con il nostro
grande gigante gentile che ci deve
accompagnare in tutti i prossimi
miliardi di anni nei quali vivremo sulla
terra e come lui ha sempre fatto dalle
trombe una delle cose che potremmo fare
è finalmente avendo le previsioni
cercare di usare di sfruttare meglio le
risorse marine
queste norme gabbie che permetteranno
finalmente di avere
un pesce sostenibile di non sfruttare le
risorse senza sapere quello che si sta
facendo e come abbia fatto finora
ecco qui tanti esempi ormai ne abbiamo
tanti nel mondo
la precedente era una gabbia delle
hawaii in hawaii si formano ormai enormi
consorzi in europa ci sono ormai tutte
queste posizioni dove le onde e i venti
si possono misurare e non solo si
possono misurare ma si possono sfruttare
questo ad esempio è un enorme serpentone
che usa l'energia delle onde molto
sostenibile
il grande gigante gentile ha tanta
energia e questo è un apparato che usa
le correnti
adesso io posso prevedere le correnti so
come far funzionare questo apparato che
come vedete sul fondo del mare e queste
sono le famose fattorie eoliche del mare
del nord
ormai il nord europa viaggia con questa
energia
speriamo presto di viaggiare anche qui
con la stessa energia grazie a tutti
[Applauso]